[TEST PATTERN SIGNAL]
[THEME MUSIC]
ANDREW BROGDON:
We mentioned this
in one of our earlier episodes.
We have Flutter
samples, and I just
wanted to make
sure everybody knew
that we have an
index for it that
is a curated list of samples.
So we're working on a
ton of samples right now.
I think I have two or three
in the pipeline myself,
and other people are always
making more on the team.
But there's also the community--
the Flutter community is also
cranking out samples,
which is great.
And so I wanted to have an
index in our samples repo
that had not just the stuff that
the Flutter developer relations
team was working on,
but also just good stuff
that the community has made
that people should also
be looking at.
And so we put
together this index.
It's in our samples repo--
you know,
GitHub.com/Fluttersamples,
and then look for the index.
And you can see a bunch
of things in here.
There's Flutter
examples from Nashad,
there's another
Flutter examples--
it's a collection of things
from one of our GDEs.
And we have just a
ton of stuff in here--
Brian Egan's
architectural samples
that I've pointed a
zillion people to.
So if you're looking for
more sample code-- you know,
you're watching
something like this,
you're probably interested
in Flutter code--
and you're looking
for more code that's
made by people who really
know what they're doing,
check out this index, because
you'll see a lot of stuff made
by a lot of good people.
OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK.
ANDREW BROGDON: We'll switch.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
You'll take a look at the
questions, answer them,
and I will continue to
investigate this bug.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Yeah, there we go.
OK.
I'm going to take Dash.
There we go.
EMILY FORTUNA: Dash can assist
with question answering.
ANDREW BROGDON: And this brings
up an important question.
Where are-- over there,
right in front of me.
So this open window is
where the question--
OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: Set
you up for success.
ANDREW BROGDON: Smart lady.
All right.
So we had a few come in.
We talked about the
comment that was helping
me find the censors page and
the Emulator settings-- thanks
again for that.
Let's see.
We had somebody ask
about whether it's
possible to use the BLoC
pattern with Angular Dart.
And yes, it is.
One of the things
people like about BLoC,
and one of the things it
was designed for, actually,
was code reuse between
Dart for Web and Flutter.
So BLoC generally will be just
business logic components--
it's taking an input on a
stream and it's outputting
its output on another stream.
There's not widgets involved,
generally, in a BLoC--
it's just pure Dart code.
And so one of the
benefits of that
is that it can run
on both platforms.
It can run both
on mobile and web,
and that's part of
what it's designed for.
So to answer your question, yes.
All right.
We had another question
come in from someone
whose YouTube account
has "locationservices"
as their name.
It's "locationservices."
Well, Mr. or Miss
Services, thank you
for commenting,
asking about importing
a file as a file versus
importing a file as a package.
So if you-- do you mind
flipping real quick just
to any file in Android Studio or
something just so we can look?
So all the way at the
top-- oh, sorry, Dart file.
Here we go.
So at the top here, we
have "import package
Flutter/services.dart," which
is being imported as a package--
that's how it's
being recognized.
You can import things
like in that same way,
even if they're in
your own project.
So if you're working on an
app and you have two files,
you know, one that's called
main.dart and another one
called widgets.dart, you can
import that one as a project,
even though it's a local file
just sitting in your project,
or you can import
it as a local file.
There's two ways to do it.
It doesn't really matter
which way you do it--
the only important thing is that
you pick one and stick to it.
And the reason is if you
import a file as package,
you know, colon, your app name,
slash, and then the file in one
place, and then
import it as import--
EMILY FORTUNA: Direct path.
ANDREW BROGDON: --just
direct path in another, Dart
actually considers those
two separate name spaces.
And so it will create two
sets of class definitions
and everything else,
even though all the code
is in the same file.
It has to do with the way
it handles the imports.
That's something they're looking
at maybe changing further
down the line.
But for right now,
that is the case.
It considers them two
separate name spaces.
So if you have an object
that you allocated
in one of those files
and you're using it
in some code that was
using the import that
was done in a different way,
you can get a type conflict,
and it'll look really weird.
It'll be like, "type
customer record
is not equal to type
customer record,"
and you're like, what
are you talking about?
You know, this came from--
I only have one customer
record class declaration
in my whole project.
But because it's imported
in two separate ways,
it counts as two.
Personally, I just do the
package way for everything.
Everybody, you know--
EMILY FORTUNA: And I actually
like to do the direct pathway.
ANDREW BROGDON: You
do the exact opposite.
EMILY FORTUNA: But
the reason I like
that is it helps for me to
distinguish between the files
that I'm writing and other
packages that I import.
But it comes down to personal
preference, I suppose.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
Like I said, it's
really pick one way--
EMILY FORTUNA:
But be consistent.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
Pick one away and go with it.
It's like when you're chopping
up vegetables to roast them,
you know?
You just pick a
size and go with it.
So.
[THEME MUSIC]